ISRAELI AND PALESTINIAN LEADERS.
ANTHONY?
>> THANK YOU.
>>> DAN SENOR IS A FORMER
FOREIGN POLICY ADVISER TO MITT
ROMNEY.
HE'S ALSO CO-AUTHOR OF "STARTUP
NATION: THE STORY OF ISRAEL'S
ECONOMIC MIRACLE" AND HAS
RECENTLY TWEETED HIS SUPPORT FOR
POSITIONS TAKEN BY THE ISRAELI
GOVERNMENT.
DAN, GOOD MORNING, GOOD TO SEE
YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> THE LAST CONFLICT LIKE THIS
BACK IN 2014 LASTED SIX WEEKS.
WE HEARD ISRAELI PRIME MINISTER
BENJAMIN NETANYAHU SAY THAT AN
IMMEDIATE END TO THE FIGHTING IS
NOT IMMINENT.
IS NOT IMMINENT I SHOULD SAY.
WHEN DO YOU THINK WE'LL SEE A
CEASE-FIRE?
>> WELL, TO YOUR POINT, YOU
KNOW, 2014 LASTED ABOUT 50 DAYS.
THE GAZA -- THE ISRAELI WAR IN
GAZA IN 2008 AND 2009 LASTED A
LITTLE OVER THREE WEEKS.
WE'RE ONLY JUST A LITTLE BIT --
LITTLE OVER A WEEK IN.
THE ISRAELI GOVERNMENT IS SEEING
THREE DYNAMICS AT WORK HERE.
ONE, THE ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT
ISSUED A RED LIGHT.
THEY OBVIOUSLY HAVEN'T ISSUED A
GREEN LIGHT.
THEY KIND OF SEE IT BETWEEN
YELLOW AND GREEN.
MEANING DO WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO
TO TAKE OUT HAMAS WHICH THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
VERY CLEAR IS A TERRORIST
ORGANIZATION, ISRAEL LEFT GAZA
IN 2005, THEY'VE BEEN SUBJECTED
TO THESE -- ISRAEL'S BEEN
SUBJECTED TO THOUSANDS OF
ROCKETS.
THE ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT
EQUATE HAMAS WITH THE PLIGHT OF
THE PALESTINIAN PEOPLE.
THEY VIEW IT AS A SEPARATE
TERRORIST ORGANIZATION.
DO WE HAVE TO DO TO DEGRADE
HAMAS' CAPABILITIES, JUST DO IT
QUICKLY.
THAT'S ONE DYNAMIC.
THEY FEEL PRESSURE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION, THE ISRAELI
GOVERNMENT DOES, BUT NOT A LOT
OF PRESSURE.
SECONDLY, THE ARAB WORLD IN THE
PREVIOUS FIGHTS AND WARS IN
GAZA, THE ARAB WORLD HAS BEEN
PUTTING ENORMOUS PRESSURE ON THE
PARTIES TO DEESCALATE AND END
THE HOSTILITIES.
WHILE THERE HAVE BEEN STATEMENTS
FROM THE ARAB WORLD, THEY HAVE
BEEN MUCH MORE -- MUCH SOFTER,
PROBABLY A PRODUCT OF RECENT
EVENTS LIKE THE ABRAHAM ACCORDS
AND OTHER CHANGES IN THE REGION.
LASTLY, THERE'S BEEN PRESSURE
FROM THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY, BUT AGAIN, NOTHING
NEAR WHAT WE SAW IN 2014, 2008,
AND 2009.
I THINK THE TEMPERATURE IS
DIFFERENT THAN IT USED TO BE.
IT FEELS VERY HOT IN THE MOMENT,
BUT RELATIVELY SPEAKING IT'S
NOT.
>> ALTHOUGH IF THESE IMAGES OF
TUMBLING BUILDINGS CONTINUE TO
APPEAR ON OUR SCREENS, THE
PRESSURE MAY BUILD.
DO YOU THINK IT'S ULTIMATELY
GOING TO TAKE A THIRD PARTY TO
STEP IN?
IS IT GOING TO TAKE THE U.S. TO
>> NO -- LOOK, I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS THREE BUCKETS
THAT THEY MAKE CLEAR IN
CONVERSATIONS THAT THEY'RE
FOCUSED ON.
THEY'RE FOCUSED ON COVID,
THEY'RE FOCUSED ON CLIMATE
CHANGE, AND THEY'RE FOCUSED ON
CHINA.
UNLESS ANY PARTICULAR ISSUE FITS
INTO ONE OF THOSE CATEGORIES,
THEY DO NOT WANT TO EXPEND A LOT
OF POLITICAL CAPITAL ON SOLVING
THAT PROBLEM.
THEY DO NOT APPEAR TO WANT TO
GET DRAGGED INTO THE
ISRAELI-PALESTINIAN CONFLICT.
AGAIN, THEY DO NOT APPEAR TO
WANT TO START NEGOTIATING WITH
HAMAS.
SO I THINK THEY WILL PLAY A
ROLE, BUT NOT A LEAD ROLE.
I THINK YOU SHOULD LOOK FOR
EGYPT NOW.
HISTORICALLY EGYPT HAS PLAYED AN
INTERMEDIARY ROLE IN BRINGING
DOWN THE TEMPERATURE IN THESE
SITUATIONS.
I THINK EGYPT'S GOING TO PLAY A
ROLE AGAIN.
BUT ISRAEL HAS MADE IT CLEAR
THAT THEY NEED A FEW MORE DAYS
HERE.
I MEAN, IF YOU LOOK AT PUBLIC
STATEMENTS, THE PRIME MINISTER
BENJAMIN NETANYAHU'S INTERVIEW
WITH JOHN DICKERSON ON "FACE THE
NATION," THEY'RE MAKING IT CLEAR
THAT THEY ARE DEGRADING HAMAS'
MILITARY CAPABILITIES, AND THEY
NEED KEEP WORKING AT IT.
I THINK WE'RE STILL PROBABLY AT
LEAST A FEW DAYS AWAY.
>> GIVEN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
CAUTIOUS APPROACH HERE, DO YOU
THINK THIS LATEST ESCALATION IN
ANY WAY CHANGES THE U.S./ISRAELI
RELATIONSHIP?
>> I THINK THAT THE ISRAELI
LEADERSHIP BELIEVES THAT THE
U.S./ISRAELI RELATIONSHIP IS IN
A STRONGER POSITION TODAY THAN
THEY WOULD HAVE THOUGHT IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
THE ISRAELI LEADERS WENT INTO
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WITH
SOME CONCERN, WITH SOME
APPREHENSION ABOUT A SERIOUS
SHIFT FROM THE APPROACH OF THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
I DON'T THINK THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO BE
ANYWHERE NEAR THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, BUT AS YOU
PREVIOUSLY REPORTED, THERE ARE
FISSURES WITHIN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AND ENORMOUS PRESSURE ON
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION FROM
PROGRESSIVES IN CONGRESS TO TAKE
A TOUGHER APPROACH TO ISRAEL.
AND SO FAR THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT DONE SO.
SO I THINK THE ISRAELI
LEADERSHIP IS SORT OF PLEASANTLY
SURPRISED BY THE SOFTER TON